Meta’s Twitter copycat isn’t
quite living up to expectations.
Days after launching on July 5th,
engagement has dropped off a cliff.
Time spent on the app declined 60%
from its peak a few days prior,
according to the software company SensorTower.
And this was during the first week it launched.
Similarly, software company SimilarWeb
reported Threads’ daily active users
dropped from 49 million to 24 million in a week.
It’s even more disappointing considering Threads
had the greatest start of
any social media app ever.
It reached 100 million users in five days -
surpassing even the rapid rise of ChatGPT.
So, what went wrong?
While the initial interest
may have appeared promising,
it’s possible this was somewhat misleading.
One factor contributing to the surge
of sign-ups how easy it is to join.
I could easily get my puppy onto Threads by
signing up through her Instagram
account with just a few clicks.
Additionally, Threads offers the feature of
transferring your Instagram followers
directly onto the new platform.
This could have amplified
the popularity of Threads,
giving a skewed perception
of genuine user engagement.
Another aspect that’s problematic
is that you can’t delete your
Threads account without deleting
your Instagram account as well.
You can deactivate Threads, but you’re
locked in unless you choose to delete both.
And privacy concerns are off the charts.
When I compare the privacy labels from
Apple's App Store, I discovered that
Threads gathers more information than
Twitter, including “sensitive info”.
That includes racial or ethnic data, sexual
orientation, pregnancy or childbirth information,
disability, religious and philosophical beliefs,
trade union membership, political opinion,
genetic information, or biometric data - which
includes fingerprints and facial recognition data.
Because it collects so much data, Threads
isn’t yet able to launch in Europe,
as collecting sensitive information requires
a higher standard of legal consent in the EU.
Meta’s track record on privacy is far from clean.
Facebook is known for collecting user data
and allowing advertisers to target them.
Besides privacy concerns,
Threads has limited features.
Unlike Twitter, there’s no option of a
home feed just for people you follow,
though such a feature is in the works.
Instead, the Threads algorithm
pushes content from people you
don’t follow based on what it
determines to be most engaging.
The goal is to keep you on
the platform for longer,
exposing you to more ads when ads come to Threads.
Additionally, the inability to
view posts chronologically on
the timeline or search for specific
posts restricts the user experience.
The true success of imitators
typically comes from offering
an improved version of the original product.
Like when Instagram took inspiration from
Snapchat to create Instagram Stories.
Instagram added new features, such
as the option to pause, rewind,
and fast-forward through stories, something
that wasn’t available on Snapchat at the time.
This enhanced the user experience, and Instagram
Stories surpassed Snapchat’s user base.
Threads, however, doesn’t
really improve upon Twitter.
It mirrors Twitter - it’s hard
to tell them apart - other than
for a few missing features mentioned earlier.
Meta’s sales pitch for Threads
appears to be that it’s not Twitter.
Zuckerberg has been trying to
brand Threads as a “kind” and
“friendly” place where politics and
news apparently won’t be emphasized.
However, it's the back-and-forth on
politics, news, and controversial
topics that makes Twitter so compelling,
drawing people in and keeping them engaged.
By the way, I’d be grateful if you followed
@Newsthink on Twitter. Link in description.
Tucker Carlson’s interview with Andrew Tate
has been seen by 92 million users on Twitter.
Tate is a controversial figure who was banned
from the platform prior to Musk taking over.
A big reason the SpaceX and Tesla CEO
acquired Twitter for $44 billion was
because he felt freedom of
speech had been restricted.
Twitter has been bracing for more competition.
About a week after Threads launched, Twitter
started sharing ad revenue with creators,
beginning with a portion of the revenue
earned from replies to their posts.
So Twitter is trying to incentivize people to
post great content there, bolstering its appeal.
But maybe it doesn’t have to
worry about the competition.
Will Threads end up in the graveyard of
other failed Meta projects, like Lasso,
Facebook’s answer to TikTok, or
Hobbi, its answer to Pinterest?
The huge drop in engagement so soon
after launch suggests it’s headed
down that direction unless the app improves.
But maybe…this wasn’t about
Threads but a bigger plan.
Threads could be part of Zuckerberg’s wider
goal to build the metaverse, a virtual reality
space that enables users to interact with each
other inside a computer-generated environment.
Meta says it plans to decentralize Threads,
meaning it will work with other non-Meta
social networks, which aligns with Meta’s vision
for the metaverse, a seamless online ecosystem
where interactions are not limited to
one specific platform like Facebook.
The rivalry with Twitter is not
confined to the virtual world.
Elon Musk and Mark Zuckerberg may be
stepping into an entirely different ring,
possibly fighting in an MMA-style match!
Who would you place your bet
on? Let me know in the comments.
As fascinating as this fight would be,
I really do hope they’re not seriously injured
as their tech companies need their big brains.
The brains behind their
platforms are skilled engineers.
It’s the kind of skill that is so
important to foster - especially today.
I highly recommend Brilliant,
a website and app where you can
brush up on your k knowledge in math, data
science, and computer science interactively.
If you're curious about how recommendation
algorithms work and how they predict content
you'd love, dive into their new
'How Technology Works' course.
Using Brilliant is part of my daily
routine. I like to dive into their
Logic puzzles which is a fantastic way
to sharpen my analytical thinking skills.
To try out Brilliant, you can
start with a FREE 30-day trial by
signing up via my custom link in the
description: brilliant.org/newsthink
And the first 200 people to sign up
through my custom link will receive
a 20% discount on Brilliant’s Premium annual
subscription, unlocking all of the offerings.
Thanks for watching, I’m Cindy Pom.